we're going to see the celebration the
completion of writing the book it's
going to get pretty crazy
[Music]
the world is a very complicated place
torah gives you a user manual what do
you think of someone that doesn't follow
the tour
after the war people thought that the
jewish nation was finished do you know
what these mean
fire yeah we're all brothers and sisters
you hungry
we're at the border between the men's
side and the ladies side people are
always asking about the women and the
separation
everyone's so easy just pass judgment
about how bad we are it's a bunch of
emotions i don't even know how to
process it
[Music]
looking good i was going to tell you to
bring a suit but i guess you you got the
memo on your own
looking dapper buddy thank you you too
thank you did you bring the sentinel
suit
got the santanello okay so what what are
we getting into today
so uh it's a really long story but to
make a long story short
all right we have this holy book called
the torah
essentially it's the old testament was
given to the jewish people by god on
mount sinai
3 33 years ago yeah and
it's also the basis for many of the what
are considered the great religions so
so obviously christianity is based on
the old testament islam
um as well more or less so
this is the book that we live by yeah
and
we're not writing a new one but what
we're doing is we're writing a new copy
of the book and we're going to see the
celebration the completion of the book
of writing the book and then
the celebration the procession of taking
it into the synagogue it's going to get
pretty crazy
written as by hand written by hand 100
of my hand
600 000 letters for how long it takes a
full year
wow so hopefully we didn't miss that we
probably didn't
but it's gonna be happening any second
we are on shlom time no offense yes no
offense buddy
my bad i came almost two hours late for
this thank you
thank you i've heard that
hello this is a solid party slum
hello right here we have a normal
neighborhood guys
and then we go right into this party
this party is happening
thank you nice to see you
[Music]
okay thank you
i see what you're doing with soybeans
okay
amazing okay thank you thank you bless
you
thank you quite a celebration
quite hectic festive yes
[Music]
lily how are you what's going on right
now they're writing the last bit of the
yeah the torah was already written in
israel by a special scribe
and then the tradition is that the
family and friends finish it off so
actually the letters are written
and then people just fill in it's like
stencil
is this very rare having a tar come into
the world like this
it's not so rare anymore i think it used
to be more rare when
when there was less money in the
community but when you know when people
start making money and then they want to
do good things with it
you basically hired someone for to write
this for a year
so what does it feel like now for you um
it feels like when you are expecting for
nine months and you have your baby
you know or like you raise your child
for 20 something years then you marry
them off
that's what it feels like this like okay
feeling of
ecstatic joy and relief that like you
did it and also
it's a tremendous um honor
i feel very humble not everyone my age
or
you know is evil to do something like
this and for me to be able to do this
was actually an honor my grandmother who
died one year ago today she was a
holocaust survivor
and um i was very very close with her
and when she passed away i said like
what can i do that's everlasting and
this is something that
that's everlasting it's a legacy that
stays forever and so that's why we
decided this is dedicated to her and
then where do you put it
it stays in the synagogue okay and it
gets read from
every sabbath and and and then if
the synagogue is used during the week it
gets red during the week too how many
pages is it well it's a scroll
this is real ink with a quill it's
written very specifically
he's trained for a long time to know how
to do this
so there there are certain amount of
people in the community that have been
trained for this
okay is it a is it a dying art or is it
growing people getting it
look he's young he's newly married young
guy
yeah young rabbi in his 20s
how can i make it
how do you feel when a torah goes into
the world what's your thoughts
it's part of my it's actually part of me
[Music]
can i describe the feeling sterny said
it was like giving birth
100
it's like the front row of concert thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what is this thing this uh it's like a
canopy
oh she's a canopy there's live music
coming from a truck
that you're going to see in a second
that's going to leave the truck is going
to lead the procession
what do you think of this event
offensively it's amazing really the
community spirit's amazing it's cool
it's awesome are you jewish or no i'm
not no yeah me neither i think it's my
first time being exposed to it was
pretty neat
we're the only two non-jews yet that my
other guy
[Music]
so now we're walking the torah through
the streets we're dancing the torah
through the streets there's a procession
with music
and the kids are all holding torches
it's a sign of honor for the torah
this is a very joyous occasion you have
to understand all of us here are
holocaust survivors
after the war people thought that the
jewish nation was finished we would
never rebuild
ourselves now all over the world it's
happening you see hundreds of people
dancing
our book the holy book that we believe
in through the streets
proudly we're not afraid of anybody it's
a very very emotional experience
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
what a cool beautiful exciting
invigorating
spiritual experience you can just
you can feel the connectivity here you
can feel the
the culture the depth and even the cop
there right
he was all uh saying how cool it felt
the community
you feel with this group now i'm in
because of my other videos but they're
they're very very accepting they've been
very accepting to me everyone's been
very kind
very open and i gotta admire i gotta
just stand from the side
the sidelines here and say
i don't know exactly what's going on i
don't know what it's like to be hasidic
i'm an outsider but as an outsider i can
observe and respect it and
admire it it's quite a beautiful thing
[Music]
basically in our community and according
to
uh religious jewish law we consider it
inappropriate for
grown men and women to dance together
okay so this is where like uh
the guys will do the dancing and the
women will like follow the procession
because again this is the way we see
things
if the women are going to be dancing it
should be more of a private thing so at
a jewish wedding which unfortunately you
have not yet been to but one day we'll
make it happen okay
there'll be like a divider in the middle
sort of so the men won't see the women
dancing and
the women sort of look at the guys
dancing but okay i'm sure you understand
why there's a difference
so why is that it's a it's a modesty
thing right yeah it's sort of setting a
boundary in a healthy place so things
don't progress from there again in our
in our values right any dating or any
almost relation between the sexes is is
for marriage only right
so so by keeping the genders separate
here that
that eliminates any temptation or yeah
any temptation anyone
going too far especially in this climate
there's the whole metoo movement or
whatever
i think i think the western world got it
wrong okay
and it's healthy to have boundaries in a
certain place so they don't end up
so people don't know they're crossing
really serious boundaries
the world is a very complicated place
and the torah gives you a sort of
user manual how to navigate life
staying out of trouble living a
meaningful life today it's so easy to
get distracted there are people i mean
i'm worried about kids today for example
because you were growing up on the
internet right playing minecraft
whatever
it's okay to play and and get your you
know everyone has to have an outlet
but some people are literally living in
a virtual world and they're gonna when
they're gonna hit
50 60 70 they're gonna say what did i do
with my life like i
didn't live in reality right the torah
is just it's a guidebook
for it's a user manual for life for go
it has things about marriage about
charity
about how to bring up children how to be
kind for health there's
it's literally it teaches us how to live
and it's
so what do you think of someone that
doesn't follow the tour i
like myself so i i love you peter you
know that you're just one of my closest
friends
and i just feel like as long as you're
living a meaningful life in your way
i'm happy for you i'm not trying to
convert you i'm trying very hard not to
come you guys
don't do that no no we're against it we
we try very hard not to convert people
but we do believe that there are very
valuable lessons in there that can
benefit all of mankind
so in a way you have to be born into the
club yeah
thank you so much thank you thank you
this is this man is he's an amazing
person a very amazing person
i just want to say thank you so much
thank you for everything you do thank
you sorry
don't worry do you know him he's very
famous
yeah yeah sure how are you feeling out
here today beautiful it's beautiful
i did one of these like a half year ago
it's a very
momentous time it's a special occasion
it's one of the
you know the biggest things big
celebrations
it's like you celebrate something that's
you know deep
and uh it's a very uh festive
event what's your name my name is pesa
pesach yeah peter nice to meet you
you guys how you doing how you guys
doing
thank you basically guys what did the
what do these mean do you know what
these mean no
fire yes was this mine
is indicative of light towards the light
so it's symbolic of leading the way
lighting up the way for the taurus role
which is really if you think about it
judeo-christian values come from this
yeah from this thing and is islam
it's a huge for us no matter the stripe
of jew you are i'm not facility in any
way shape or form
okay you know but you you you you blend
in with the hasidic's no problem because
you know what we're all
we're all brothers and sisters in the
world we really are
that's all of us yeah and you have
something like this which is just a
celebration
yeah goodness yeah that's all it is yeah
and you see the pure
joy in people and pure joy joy and
that's because
this is it it's just a legacy more than
anything else whether you believe what's
in there or not
whether anybody believes what's in there
or not okay where it came from
what you're seeing here is a tradition
of 2 000 years old yeah
handed father to son to son to parents
and
grandkids all of it and it's all based
on this
what a joy yeah passing down of the
story
it's beautiful you do whatever you want
with that story whatever you want with
it but this
this transcends all lines all of us
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
this is this is the female section
and so ellie brings it in for everyone
to touch
yeah she's ringing goodbye so the women
and the kids can kiss it
[Music]
[Music]
so as you may have noticed we are now
joined by a few more toros that were
taken out of the synagogue
and they're coming out this is the
synagogue so
i don't remember this being the
synagogue but i guess it is okay
because i saw it from a different angle
whatever so basically the torahs are
coming out
to greet the new torah if we consider
the torah like a live document
yeah just because it was given to us
more than 3 000 years ago doesn't mean
it doesn't apply anymore it's continuous
it stays alive and its rules are always
applicable so it's the idea is that
these torahs are like coming to greet
their new companion
which will be with them in the ark
because it's not just they're not just
objects they're it's like they're alive
so they're like they're living breathing
objects well not
not physically but on a spiritual level
yes they yeah so they're
they're like coming out because they're
also part of the celebration yeah
basically
if there's one mistake even one letter
is partially rubbed out or whatever
then the whole torah is no good for
example there's a computer program
that scans the whole torah because for
one human being to go through six
hundred thousand letters would be insane
wait wait
yeah they've developed a computer
program that automatically scans it and
can see if a letter's out of place or
whatever
yeah so and if it's out of place they've
got to go back and forth you have to
stop using it until it's been fixed
and the torah that cannot be fixed has
to be buried like like a like a body
like a human body because
they're they're live beings ellie and
sterny are
the representatives of what yiddish
guide is really all about
it's they they have the their inside
is so pure and they're able to
share it with the external world with
people around them on
all levels that's what's so amazing
about them
so they're saying some prayers before
the uh before the torah goes into the
the ark see the ark over there the ark
okay let's go up there yeah so there are
prayers before it goes into their
prayers and then they're probably gonna
dance a little more
okay
[Music]
the tour is going here the tour's going
here it's so safe so that the
god forbid don't get stolen and those
little things down there are little
pointers when
when we're reading the torah we point to
the verse and the word that we're
supposed to be
reading because you're not supposed to
touch the actual scroll with your
with your beer hands supposed to try to
avoid doing that
[Music]
these are the ten commandments
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
all right guys hear that hear how quiet
it is
i'm thinking that's not gonna last so
here we are at the
ballroom dancing dancing right yes sir
music
sit down and eat it's got a pink theme
pink purple theme
yep and candles all right romantic this
is a rabbi right this is the rabbi
the same picture again today is his um
it's
rabbi yeah okay so in hasidum
there are many sex right like 200 sex or
something there's a lot of stages
and then there's like a lot of small
walls so this is lubavitch which is
one of the big ones satmar is like the
very conservative like the most
conservative right
you're satmar um labovich is a little
more
jovial humorous yeah
chill yeah yeah okay does it say that
yeah it sounds like this is the woman's
side
the woman inside yeah we can walk
through
[Music]
women's side
beautiful
here we have the men's side
[Music]
dance floor quite a setup
hey guys there we go look at this setup
oh and there he is let's go slow you
hungry
anytime jews do anything we celebrate we
eat we drink and we have a good time
that's the way our religion works there
isn't an issue with liquor
or alcohol and his sedum is there not at
all
it's completely open yeah we believe
that everything's healthy in moderation
some people will take it farther than
others but as a general rule
we we all drink look at this guy he's a
model he's a model
oh thank you yeah i think so
does every jewish party look like this
not everyone they all have the basic
elements of
of people food and alcohol but this is
really this one's really over the top
multi-camera shots no and all look at
the all the centerpieces the lighting
the bar yeah there's a lot going on here
we do have a good time i promise
i'm not living a sad life i guarantee
it's something that people think when
they
think of a very conservative religion
like and it's seen him i want to make it
clear to you guys
judaism is is this this wide very broad
you have uh sasha barack owen on one
side right
yeah he's not wearing a stremmel not yet
um not yet
and then you have hasidum from an
outsider it's interesting that
someone can be very conservative and go
out and party and drink
i mean party in the meet up together and
drink right so again
it's guys only on this side the women
are on the other side of the wall and
you can check that out in a minute
we believe everything is good in
moderation and we believe that
everything that god created can be used
in a positive way in the service of god
so alcohol and we all have our our
what shall we say vices we all have our
things that we have
we get caught up in our head whatever
you have a couple shots you can get out
of that mindset and
sometimes you can leave some of your
some of your nonsense behind it could
take you to a purer place
now if you drink too much you're gonna
end up you know puking in the toilet
yeah so you have to you have to know how
to do everything in moderation
and that's the key to living a very
meaningful life
a spiritual life in a very physical
world the women are on the other side
here yeah they're on the other side of
the bar
so after the event they meet in the
parking lot yeah like like if my wife
was here i'd take her home i'd drop her
off whatever you would meet outside
afterwards or in the hallways listen if
i needed to talk to her i'd go to the
i'd go to the end i'll show you okay and
i'll mention for someone to
to call her but yes general rule it's
separate and we believe that these
boundaries are very healthy
yeah what would you say to someone that
like they think that's a that's a bad
thing that
the men and women are suffering you have
your opinion i have mine i respect yours
please respect mine right right right
yeah i'm not trying to push my agenda on
anyone else god forbid
that's not my question it's just when i
get a lot with the hasidic videos
i've done people are always asking about
the women and the separation
yeah and i try to explain it hey look
it's not my religion
i just i just i i show it i talk to
people i respect it
but it's a common question yeah but i
think that if people are open-minded
enough
they can see that there can be benefit i
understand trust me i understand
why people would want to mingle with
women that makes perfect sense to me but
there also is a benefit in keeping
things pure
and there are you know there's a lot of
chaos that happens in the outside
world between guys and girls and we can
avoid a lot of that by keeping to our
traditions guys you got you
this is no man's land right here we're
at the border between the men's side and
the ladies side
as you can see it's mostly closed off
but it also is open
so that if i needed to talk to my wife
on the other side or i wanted to say hi
to a neighbor or whatever i could do
that
but as a general rule for the most part
it will be separated
just to chat with other people we would
probably stay on i would stay on my side
of the fence
[Music]
my
[Music]
to conclude the strength of a woman if
you didn't know by now is superpower
almost unnatural tonight is about a
woman that despite her dire
circumstances which is my grandmother
she used the power to rise up leadership
family
she was able to pass down their power to
a granddaughter
may power continue to inspire many women
for generations to come
the rabbit talked many times about the
word israel in russia davis for
yeah isis
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
how does it feel feels amazing it feels
really humbling
uh really special really special that's
that's true
so emotional it's a bunch of emotions i
don't even know how to process it yeah i
can't wait to this event to be over to
go home and to really like
okay what happened what happened over
here why did i feel so emotional
but i feel it just added written down
the torah that was given so many years
ago
and uh it still continues and continues
no matter what it's something that will
always be in the family basically it's a
family heirloom
it stays in the family for generations
to come here's family already
i told him from now on any family event
he has to join yeah i feel very welcome
with this community so thank you guys
thank you very much peter for coming and
i appreciate it
thank you for showing the beauty of our
culture and on today's day and ages you
know
everyone's so easy just past judgment
about how bad we are and how negative
and all that
right so important for people to see the
beauty yes and it is
it comes through yeah thank you thank
you
you guys are awesome thank you so much
thank you thank you
it was really nice that you got to
experience this and i
experienced it on the on a deeper level
because you were here so that's
one thing i would say and another thing
is just like
i don't know keep your eyes open you
know be open to learning about other
people
right right don't form your opinions
until you know
until you know those people you're
forming the opinions about that's all
fact
guys i hope you felt some of that uh ton
of energy
ton of positivity a lot of sweat on the
dance floor is like running of the bulls
uh but you can't fake raw emotions
and there was plenty of positive
beautiful raw emotions so
i hope that gives you another
perspective into the hasidic jewish
community
uh it's a just to see them as a complex
world
yeah and that's one angle in so thanks
for coming along
great to see you again shalomi oh he's
always the best making videos with shlom
and uh we'll we'll be doing this we'll
do it again
see you sometime so can i tell him can i
tell him you just got back from you can
tell him we'll see if we can leave it in
yeah i just got back from i just got
back from kabul afghanistan
met with the last jew who lives there it
was nuts
uh always always a crazy time in
afghanistan and uh
thank god i'm alive to tell the story
shlomi goes in deep
you you're you're actually a little more
adventuresome than me these days
i know you're going to be in afghanistan
yeah okay but i'm not going in as a
hasidic joke
that's next level i have to cover up you
tied them up
all right all right guys thanks for
coming along till the next one
[Music]
you